la maroquinerie c'est l'école de la
minutie il faut 8 heures en moyenne pour
confectionner un seul sac à main de la
découpe à la finition aux ateliers
d'armançon le savoir faire des employés
et depuis quarante ans au service des
plus grandes marques de la maroquinerie
de luxe et le secteur a le cuir solide
il résiste à la crise au point
qu'aujourd'hui la société décide de
faire revenir en bourgogne
des emplois qui avait été délocalisée au
vietnam suffisamment rare pour être
expliquée on rapatrie surtout des
productions de façon permettent de
répondre à la vitesse qui nous est
demandée par les clients
aujourd'hui notre hymne au vietnam est
trop loin et ne veut plus satisfaits a
complètement la vitesse qui nous est
demandé
donc tous ces emplois là et tout ce
qu'ils fabriquaient sur des nouvelles
couleurs bas est rapatrié en europe sur
nos usines france dans les deux ans 100
postes seront créés à saulieu et une
vingtaine à semur une aubaine pour les
jeunes diplômés des filières
professionnelles de la région
moi je trouve que c'est même
encourageant pour peut-être qu'ils les
jeunes qui sortent de l'école on sait
que à la sortie d'école ils ont
peut-être un travail peut-être même sur
je pense ce qu'il ya l'air d'avoir quand
même de l'avenir et le luxe je pense que
c'est quand même un domaine qui vie quoi
mais comme il n'est pas toujours simple
de recruter les ateliers d'armançon
reste en lien étroit avec les formations
maroquinerie proposées au lycée de
montbard pour travailler main dans la
main
on ne peut leur apporter toute la partie
formation pratique en entreprise et le
savoir faire que nous avons acquis
depuis de nombreux dizaine d'années est
par contre on a besoin de déformation en
externe sur le greta ou sur l'éducation
et celles qui leur apportent toute la
partie théorie dont ils ont besoin pour
connaître le cuir connaître le métier et
comprendre ce qu'ils font le site de
semur que le patron surnomme le paquebot
a donc le vent en poupe dans le luxe le
made in france fait vendre et même
revenir les emplois une belle éclaircie
pour toute l'industrie bourguignonne